hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play
discipline and sha ha cha reading the
note the chillon has been curtain off
due to the electricity problems we have
been having no joke the barricade is
loud alright pick up and everywhere down
here I think it's time to oh I'm so
tired I think I'll go take a nap
ah got here get that out of here
no thank you I don't want any I'd rather
not so here Oh click click oh that's
much brighter it's 2 V nope - no ok no
creaky creak creak creak super creak aah
click click click click and tick let me
turn on the shower No
Oh - a dead door won't budge
- b-but my room is not this way what I
the door lock on from to a seems to be
very fragile maybe you can break with a
powerful light of you well you're
talking about yourself you do know
better
the metal bar lock on the barricade to
the salon looks rusty you might be able
to corrode it with some acid good thing
I got some acid right here in my back
pocket ah yeah it's an ass joke hello
click it so the cool others but I like
nice tough
hey all you people in the other houses
you want to give me a hand here cuz I'm
probably going to die click click left
click click loved ok was there anything
in here worth getting nope okay honey
thing bye bye goodnight person in to be
your snap crackle oh this looks so warm
and inviting
ahh oh I'm not going to sleep now
well really oh really sleeping
hey is that a crowbar
I remember seeing any of that
whoa hahaha chair stop being such a
rebel get down from their chair you are
chair
oh crap this is freaky and awesome but
mostly freaky
that's like the coolest thing I've ever
seen in amnesia holy crap oh oh oh you
dick what was that supposed to be I was
not expecting that
hours
oh no tip out this cat that's bad
we need to turn on the power the power
distribution board is located in the
salon but we should borrow grandfather's
lantern from the storage in room two a
before heading downstairs in the dark
Oh what was that
stop it now don't be like that
don't be a dick why the alarm ring just
as I on this something behind there can
I get through there ah I knew there was
gonna be something like that
ha fifty thalers loud down and now numb
No
hey y'all oh dang under there
so anyway no I don't need to do this I
don't need to light any of those huh
gosh stop it that is stupid
ah oh man what's up the super super
speedy whoosh man oh I don't like that
okay ah
so dark so so dark what do we got open
up open up give me your saw Salem unum
give me your Foom
don't do that dump that now ooh this
looks nice ah ah spider God butter stop
[ __ ] you guys biter
all right good jar for acid
I'm guessing and not Lander get out of
your spine I don't want to be with you
I don't be near you or around you just
booze man is that a real move Manor I
think you taking this man that sounds
like a real move man
Wow to Ramona no I'd only doing that
removes butter in their room oh ah
god damn it really really oh go away
spider go away spider go away go away
spider I don't like you stay over there
no no get away
Oh God
get away get away get away get away get
away I know what I need to do Oh Baba
boy oh all right you're the acid y'all
use it man min here we go
Oh hurry up Oh hurry up oh I don't have
time for this
oh so not much time for this any day now
yeah okay everyone good run power come
where does these Moosman come from of
course that makes sense
oh yeah your closets hidin
ooh more salem through them damn it now
down it down him like a nightmare I
could hide in there oh this is the UM
hello hello who is it please stop it I
don't like that unlike that at all I
like that exactly nothing
ah I hate these wheels need to activate
the electrical fuse what oh okay
danger electricity yeah I'm the best I'm
an engineer I'm doing okay those awesome
thing now what can I get out of that
house now I think you know after I saw
the first monster I think I would leave
much quicker than I did before
ah look outside that's good huh how
about uh how about that outside can I go
please jeez okay escape please just
hurdle over it just hurdle over it man
really really good really escape is like
right there there's somebody's house
he's gonna
something behind there no all right what
was the point of turning on the power up
buffer tube boo boo okay you better
leave the mansion as fast as possible
something is horribly wrong with this
place maybe you're gonna skip through
the basement
a few maybe you can escape through the
front door what are you doing did you
smash that door screw it I'm out here
I'm out of here
gah yeah oh where are these special
chests with the items oh my oh boy this
come from why can't I go out that front
door ah no this is that it oh there's a
bad idea oh this is a bad idea
oh you know feet so I can run away be
sure come here
just back out okay I'm just going I'm
just going you can catch up basement is
right here ha ha what's this what's this
whizzes was this what is this motives
yes please
yes please yeah please go a spider yes
yes yes yes yes yes big barrel gigantic
barrel what's with these different size
barrels I don't know I don't care
lizzi's ah I don't even know there's
nothing binder okay obviously I love
this but let me see what's down here for
move side more spiders oh there's so
many moves man what's this this is
different I'm gonna blow this up blink
no okay blow this up I'm going to blow
you away boo boom yeah
subtle low frame rates
okay thank you Wow fu Oh get away from
me spider
all I see what I have to do that's
probably why it's lagging because these
are all physical objects and physics
breaking down an age oh it's not meant
to be a physical simulator just gotta
get there we go oh come on that's not
even fair oh that's not even fair that
is not cool
OVC deck ah away
I was like you can kill this infinite
he'll might be working buddies murdering
Trek that you care that's the official
name of this era was I like to do
doesn't seem to be dying huh hook wow
that that water monster seems a whole
lot angrier than other water monsters
everything ah do you have the box Oh No
good god I want you get on boxes when I
tell you to get all boxes my sandy is
not doing well
all right perfectly good now oldest if
there isn't a water monster about to
devour me hmm get away
ha what is that what what is that
I hear like a moose man banging on the
doors
Oh stepping banging on my box rook rook
got it okay I don't know where this
leads but I'm going up there to screw
that and that water monster was all up
in my business
now down it down him okay what's that
that looks bored
okay I'm guessing I need this somehow Oh
put that down there okay I see it I see
it I see I need to replace some gears
okay I'm not I'm not like kidding myself
that water monster sounds so much than
anything I've encountered okay what we
got here
the machinery is fixed but the cogwheels
they're steel music search for the
cognizant used a lever to start the
machine levers to start the machine
engine do not forget to use the right
voltage the machine requires twelve
kilovolts here but that gear that gear
looks like it's curable alright I'm all
out of time but holy hell I wonder you
just turn to the cogwheels blah blah
blah but holy hell this this this this
custom story is not [ __ ] around so
thank you all so much for watching and
as always see you next part bye bye